vielen herzlichen Dank Frau plattiell in
der Tat die deutsch-polnischen
Beziehungen sind in einer schwierigen
Phase
möglicherweise in der schwierigsten
Phase seit dem Ende des Kalten Krieges
wir haben
in mehreren Fragen
mit der polnischen Regierung
auseinandergehende Meinung
das betrifft zum einen die
Auseinandersetzung mit Brüssel also die
Frage der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
welche
Maßnahmen sind notwendig damit überall
in der Europäischen Union die Grundwerte
eingehalten werden
da gibt es eine Diskussion mit mit
Brüssel dazu es gibt zweitens die Frage
wie gehen wir mit der Geschichte um mit
der Last der Geschichte deutschland hat
im Zweiten Weltkrieg in Polen
unglaublich gewütet wir haben es 6
Millionen Tote in Polen 3 Millionen
Juden drei Millionen nicht nicht
jüdische polnische Bevölkerung wir haben
immense materielle Schäden
waren auch polnische Mitbürger die dort
umgebracht das habe ich ja gesagt ja ja
ja und also insofern ist es notwendig
sich mit dieser Sache
auseinanderzusetzen
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber auch
feststellen dass die Art und Weise wie
das geschieht im Moment also durch die
Präsentation von
Reparationsforderungen in astronomischer
Höhe ja 1,3 Billionen Euro
dass das im Moment eigentlich dazu
beiträgt den Westen zu spalten
beziehungsweise insbesondere Deutschland
und Polen zu spalten und gerade in einen
Moment in dem wir sprachen darüber über
die Krise in der Ukraine wo westliche
Geschlossenheit so wichtig ist in dem
Moment wird das aufgebracht also das
halte ich für für sehr gefährlich
andererseits haben die Polen recht
gehabt in der Art und Weise wie sie uns
oder jedenfalls dass sie uns darauf
hingewiesen haben dass wir in unserer
russland-politik uns in den vergangenen
30 Jahren also seit Ende des Kalten
Krieges massiv getäuscht haben
Polen hat uns immer wieder auf die
energiepolitische Abhängigkeit vom vom
von Russland hingewiesen sie haben auch
darauf hingewiesen
Polen hat uns immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass dieses Credo also diese
Glaubenssatz
Sicherheit in Europa ist nur mit
Russland und nicht gegen Russland
möglich auch das ist
gescheitert und Polen hat uns hat uns
darauf hingewiesen also insofern glaube
ich gibt es da natürlich auch ein
gewisse Berechtigung für polnische
Kritik aber wir müssen jetzt alles tun
und da bin ich bei ihrem Wort Vertrauen
das verloren gegangene Vertrauen in
dieser Region wieder zu gewinnen da geht
es um die Frage der Führungsrolle
Deutschland in der Region da geht es um
die Frage wie es mit Krieg und Frieden
in der Zukunft weitergehen wird und da
müssen muss Deutschland Farbe bekennen
ich will auch sagen und das ist
eigentlich der positive Aspekt dabei
dass die Beziehung im Bereich der
Zivilgesellschaft und die Bereich der
Gesellschaft sich doch in den letzten 30
Jahren in einer Art und Weise entwickelt
haben dass die man als sehr sehr positiv
bezeichnen kann manche bezeichnen sogar
das Wunder der Aussöhnung also insofern
ist die Grundlage der Beziehungen in
Ordnung ist gut aber es gibt eben diese
Probleme und diese Probleme kann man
durch konkrete Politik überwinden
insbesondere indem man verloren
gegangenes Vertrauen wieder aufbaut sie
kennen Polen auch gut ich glaube eine
sehr intensive deutsch-polnische
Freundschaft die Kind Mutter meiner
Kinder ist ist Polen meine Kinder sind
genau
zu wenig für diese Freundschaft
also eine Freundschaft ist keine
Einbahnstraße ja ist wie mit allem Geben
und Nehmen ob das immer im gleichen
Prozentsatz ist ist ja in den seltensten
Fällen so
aber ich glaube und das kriege ich auch
mit weil er nur die Mutter meiner Kinder
polnisch ist das ist auch ment gerade
wirklich politisch
genutzt wird wie oft um so ein bisschen
Stimmung zu machen und dann
genau und wer wer würde da natürlich
auch nicht immer gut als äh als
Feindbild geben als der der deutsche ja
und das kriege ich auch deshalb so genau
mit wenn also meine gerade jetzt das war
früher weniger wenn mein wenn man
praktisch rüber fährt und hatten
deutsche Kennzeichen dann und ja und
dann sprechen so der ein oder andere und
bei mir ich spreche ja im Moment Deutsch
aber wenn dann die Mutter meiner Kinder
daneben ist die versteht das natürlich
alles erzählt was sie gerade gesagt
haben dann kann Zufall sein aber
manchmal habe ich das Gefühl dass sowas
es anführt und das spaltet das spaltet
die Menschen der spaltet Europa und
gerade in so einer Situation wenn man
kriegt hat denke ich mal sollte man
näher zusammenrücken und vielleicht mal
ein bisschen runterfahren und diese Zahl
die sie da gesagt haben diese eben
gesagt haben ja gut ich denke mal der
ein oder andere wird sich über den
Präsidenten der da drüben ist schon Bild
gemacht haben aber vielleicht sollte mal
ein bisschen in sich gehen und überlegen
was er damit eigentlich anrichtet
vielleicht können wir das mal ein
bisschen auseinander nehmen handical was
genau davon ist denn Wahlkampf Getöse
wenn es angesprochen das ist jetzt Wahl
ja in Polen und welches sind die Punkte
in die wir reingehen müssen die wir
verbessern müssen wo sind die Dinge die
uns einen und wo sind die Dinge die uns
beiden ja also die die Dinge die uns
Spalten habe ich ja schon genannt dass
ich sie Diskussion um Europa das ist die
Frage der Geschichte und das ist die
Frage des Umgangs mit Russland
und wir sollten in unserem Beziehungen
mit Polen vor allen Dingen zum einen
Vertrauen aufbauen aber wie wie machen
wir das ja und ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir auch die Jugend
Zusammenarbeit weiter fördern wir haben
das deutsch-polnische Jugendwerk das ist
seit 1991 wirksam seit diesem Zeitpunkt
sind drei Millionen Deutsche und Polen
oder haben drei Millionen Deutsche und
junge Polen an diesem Austausch
teilgenommen und wenn ich heute einer
fragt wo möchtest du oder wo sollten wir
am meisten ausgehen würde ich sagen drei
Dinge Jugend Jugend Jugend das ist die
Zukunft und das müssen wir das müssen
wir tun aber wir müssen auch die in die
Vergangenheit schauen und sie und aus
der Vergangenheit lernen das was in was
Deutschland den Polen angetan hat ist
ist wirklich
einmalig ja und zusammen natürlich mit
dem mit dem was was den Juden was den
Juden angetan worden ist ich würde auch
gerne dazu sagen weil darf ich noch
einfach nur hier dass dass wir diese
diese Dinge müssen und deswegen ist es
auch so wichtig ich war ja Vorsitzender
Expertenkommission für die Gründung
diese die Schaffung dieses Denkmals für
die ermordeten Polen und das muss jetzt
schnell vorangebracht werden weil das
auch wirklich etwas ist wir setzen uns
moralisch mit diesen Dingen auseinander
aber die Frage der Reparation ist eine
Frage die spaltet und die jetzt nicht
gleichzeitig in vielen Dingen Herr
Schüssler ja auch noch Erz konservativ
auch in der katholischen Kirche Polen
noch erzkonservativ muss man da mehr in
die Zukunft gehen unbedingt
parallel zusammengezuckt wie mit diesem
Billionen die ihn in Bildung Bildung
Bildung in
jugendarbeitsprogramme wenn man dieses
Geld reinstecken müssen
im übrigen unsere Bestimmung ist der
Mensch ist dafür darum heißt mein erstes
Buch himmlischen Himmel heißt Himmel
heißt immer Aufgabe aus dieser Welt ein
Stück Himmel zu machen das können wir ja
wir haben alle Möglichkeiten dazu
Homosexuelle beispielsweise sind
gesegnet werden ich schicke keinen Weg
meine eigene wenn mein Erzbischof gesagt
wir segnen alles ich segne Häuser ich
segne Umspannwerk gegen Autos Tiere und
Menschenrechte
ich zu weit mit gesagt wurde nein ist
mir aber völlig egal weil wir sind
Weltkirche das heißt diese Weltkirche
finde da Deutschland was heißt einfach
wir machen zwei wir Menschen segnen die
zu uns kommen und gesegnet werden wollen
ist doch die Schönste was es gibt wenn
jemand kommt würdest du Benedikt was
gutes zu mir sagen das ist seine Arbeit
das ist das muss ich tagtäglich machen
darf weil
diese diese deutsch polnische Aussöhnung
die funktioniert ja gerade deswegen weil
Jugendliche offen sind und weil die das
mittragen und und und die Zukunft sind
für uns also ich
bin da bei allen dabei und ich hatte
wahnsinnig interessiert zu tun ja wenn
jemand der Bundestag ankommt und sagt
Segen sie uns lassen Sie es bitte der
kommt nicht so ich habe keine Angst
aber nochmal zurück zum ernsthaften
Thema welche Bringschuld besteht er
lassen sie uns auf beide Seiten dieser
Freundschaft blicken ja wir also vor
allem die Meinung von Deutschland auch
aus jetzt die polnische Seite ja also
ich glaube die polnische Seite wäre gut
beraten ihre Kritik nicht immer nur per
Megafon auf dem Kirchturm
auszubringen sondern man kann die
Diplomatie ist hat doch auch ihre
Vorteile auch wenn der weinbergsiegen
vorhin angezweifelt hat man kann viele
Dinge auch anders lösen als
Diplomatie wie gesagt halt das spaltet
uns und dient einem einzigen ein Putin
ja also insofern insofern ist es glaube
ich schon bedeutsam dass dass die dass
die Tonlage mit der wir miteinander
umgehen entsprechend ist zweitens ist es
ist es wichtig dass wir begreifen dass
unsere gemeinsame Zukunft Europa ist ein
Europa der Vaterländer ein Europa das
nicht handlungsfähig ist wie wie es der
polender einigen in Polen vorschwebt ist
mit Sicherheit nicht das was wir heute
was wir heute brauchen
sie mittlerweile kann man sagen aus
amerikanischer Sicht ist der Polen fast
schon das bessere Deutschland verhandeln
Sie gerne mehr Diplomatie mit Polen ist
beispielsweise mit Deutschland also ich
möchte auch die Stanze brechen für nicht
nur für Amerika für Polen weil hier
sitzt keine richtige Vertreter Polens
also ich muss natürlich sagen wenn man
eine Einmischung aus Deutschland in die
innere Angelegenheiten von der
polnischen Regierung oder der polnischen
gewählten Demokrat
Vertreter immer wieder hört das nervt
die Polen ich gebe ihnen konkreten
Beispiel es war immer wieder hat man die
Polen auf primal gestellt in Deutschland
dass die keine Flüchtlinge aus
Afrika oder aus arabischen Länder
aufgenommen haben man hat aber vergessen
dass die Polen ganze Menge Millionen
hunderte von 1000 Leute zum Beispiel aus
Ukraine aufgenommen haben und das geht
jetzt nach dem 24
Februar weiter was die Polen machen die
Polen öffnen deren Wohnungen deren
Häuser wo die Leute ein absolut
bewundert hätten nicht die Leute in
Container oder in Zelte wo die sich
ablehnen und so weiter also die Polen
haben
wir auch viel Geld als Menschen zu
helfen ich glaube Deutschland hat die
zweite Deutschland hat die zweit höchste
Zahl von von Flüchtlingen aufgenommen
Bewunderung des gesehen die ersten waren
natürlich jetzt die nächsten die die
Grenzen aufgemacht haben und da ist auch
ein Stimmungswandel gegenüber dem
Klischee die Polen das sind konservative
erdkatholische wollen nichts von den
anderen Wissen Leute ganz im Gegenteil
und dann noch ein Punkt ganz kurz zu
wissen ja was und wir sind ja auch
hauptsächlich zum Thema Russland Putin
und so weiter was die Polen Polen waren
immer zwischen Deutschland und Russland
und von beiden Seiten aber es war
zweiter Weltkrieg katastrophal was sie
hier abgekriegt haben aber vergessen Sie
bitte nicht das historisch gesehen waren
die Russen wesentlich unangenehmer für
den polnischen Nachbar das war schon bei
den Heilung im 18 Jahrhundert das war
dann nach dem Polen ihre eigene
Souveränität bekommen hat haben die
Sowjets im Jahre
2019 oder 2020 die Polen angegriffen mit
4000 Tagen da gab es die bekannten
Wunder an der Weichsel
schwierige Situation in der Polen sich
auch jahrzehntelang befunden hat auch
jetzt in dieser Situation
angetan auch wir reden über Grenzen die
großen haben wir stalin hat verschoben
die Grenze es stalin hat ein Teil
Deutschland in Polen geschenkt und ein
Teil Polens hat sich selbst eingenommen
und mit allen bevölkerungsumsinnungen
und den ganzen Strategie wir gehen jetzt
nur in eine ganz kurze Pause sehen aber
bei uns geht's gleich spannend weiter
gleich sprechen wir hier in dieser
Sendung überrascht statt diese brutalen
Bilder von diesem Bahnhof die gehen uns
alle nicht mehr aus dem Herzen Carsten
Stahl war dort hat mit dem Opfer unter
Mutter gesprochen das ist das gleiche
hier bei 8:15 Uhr Pause